Hey, what's going on as bill burn? It's
the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
December 29th, 2014 this is about
as loud as I'm going to get.
By the way. I might even bring it down
here. You know what I'm saying? Oh, today,
last week it was a rough one.
It, oh. Um, I actually, uh,
have a bunch of relatives over at my
house and they're still sleeping because,
uh, you know, they went out
last night and I'm an old man.
I'm an old man.
I was in bed my fucking 10 30 fucking
Versie called me driving back from the
clubs. I think I fell asleep twice
during his conversation and it was funny.
He was like, I would wake back up to
him going like, oh, did I lose you?
And I would wake up and I
would immediately lie and
just be like, no, no, no.
I'm listening. I'm listening. And I woke
up this morning mad at myself. Like,
why did I feel the need to lie there?
What am I practicing for when like,
I really need to lie.
What's wrong with saying,
yeah, I fell asleep.
Was I concerned about Paul
versus failings like Paul,
I find you so boring that I was wide awake
at the beginning of that sentence and
by the end of it I was asleep. That
wasn't the case. It was late at night.
I was an old man. I had a big
steak dinner. Oh my God. Oh,
belly fat face is fucking back.
All right.
I have been eating like a fucking maniac.
I've been cooking bacon like a little
twinkle toes there and I've just been
shoving everything down my pie hole.
Oh fat face.
Billy is back. Like you remember when they
did back to the future of the sequels,
they shot part two and part
three at the same time.
That's how my fat face is coming back.
It's like I'm,
I'm making part two and part three
once you make bill none of your fucking
business, but I'll tell you
anyways, and I'm actually,
I'm actually gonna make a
a a Turkey pot pie today.
I'm like, you know, it's fucking, you
know, it's cold out. I'm a pussy now.
At this point, it's like 58 degrees.
I'm like, oh my God, this little Cho,
I love some Turkey pot pie
and I'm going to go out in the kitchen.
I'm going to put on it.
This is,
this is how far I've changed since
you guys are listen to this podcast,
I'm going to unapologetically walk out
into my kitchen, put on a fucking apron.
All right, and I'm gonna,
I'm gonna try this.
I'm trying to make a flaky crust.
We think about that.
You know what I love how uncomfortable
it's making you right now, not you,
the other people. You're not
uncomfortable. I don't give a fuck.
But the rest of you, the rest of you,
people are so fucking homophobic.
You can't listen to another man say
flaky crust. I'm going to say it again.
I'm going to go out in the kitchen.
I'm going to put on an apron
and I'm gonna make a flaky
the crust.
And I
have, I'm actually sort of embarrassed
at the level of excitement that I have to
fucking try this, this thing out,
because I usually just use shortening.
I never use bottom. So we'll see
how it works out. Other than that,
the fucking, the inside is the fucking
easiest, right? What do you got to, yeah,
you got the trinity of Fucking Shit,
right? The evil fucking what do you got?
Your carrots, your salary.
You fucking Alec Onions,
right? You stick them in
some butter, right? Make sure
they're clear fucking store.
I'm a little bit, then you had some other
bullshit of the other bullshit, right?
And then you throw it in the fucking
the crust there. You got many,
put it in there and you tell everybody,
get out in the kitchen and
fucking eat something. All
right. And then as they say,
oh my God, this is delicious.
You feign a humility. Well,
you know, just something, I just flipped
it up. Yours. Oh, did you like it all?
That's great.
Let me leave the room so you can guys
can all talk about how awesome I am.
All right, I'm being too loud here,
being too loud, my own fucking house. Um,
but this is what I've
actually done a cave.
If you're like me right now and
you are in the depths of a sugar,
salt downward spiral.
Okay.
And you're waking up in the morning like
that classic Stevie Ray Vaughan Story.
Ever hear that story when he was so
like addicted to alcohol and drugs.
It was like four in the morning and
he's standing in an alley somewhere in
Europe and he's puking up blood.
And when he's done,
he looks at his buddy and he said,
I needed it
drink.
That's how I feel right now with this
fucking the shit that I've been eating,
you know? And I've actually traced it back
and went back to that pork chop I had.
That's what threw me off the rails.
I was doing well.
And then I had a fucking pork chop with
and I gave it a little butter Beth.
And that was it. It sounded
so fucking gay. I know.
I gave a butter Beth
to a pork chop and um,
put it in a little in his little fucking
towels with the Hoodie on it that you
do for a baby.
I did that to my little pork chop.
I don't know why. I'm doing this to
you guys. It's like I hate myself.
So I want to make you guys uncomfortable
with all these horrible fucking images.
I'm sorry. All right, Jesus, that's
gotta be a record five minutes in.
I'm already apologizing to you. So, um,
so I've done been doing this weird thing
where I've been eating like shit yet
forcing myself to go work out and uh,
you know, when you're eating like
shit and you're trying to work out,
your body's just like, dude, I don't
want to fucking do this. You know,
if you're eating the right, your body's
like fucking dragging you down there. So,
um, I'm doing that awful middle aged
guy thing where I'm eating like,
Shit, dude, I did one day, I
think it was two nights ago.
I'm sitting around, you know,
it's the usual thing, right?
The trees look, you know,
looking sad because everyone
stopped watering it, right?
The Christmas tree really lives
the life of a fucking boy band.
You know what I mean?
It's discovered and it's a fucking star.
And then it's over and it all
goes down in like a month.
So now my tree sitting and
starting to wilt, right.
There's a bunch of
leftovers in the fridge.
Everybody's just fucking passed out in
a food coma in every different room.
You mean everybody's just so fucking,
it's literally like
you're in a crack house,
but it's food and everybody's just
fucking passed out all over. You didn't,
you don't even know half the people's
names and your house in any sense of a
schedule. It's just,
it's just, there's no,
everybody's sitting down
to eat dinner. That was too
long, days ago. Now it's just,
just eat whenever and I fucking
for dinner one night I had,
I had two Boddington's to Guinness.
Um, and then on an assortment of
dumplings from leftover Chinese food,
one chicken, one Veggie, one pork.
We had three orders and I had to one
or two of each of those with those four
fucking stout beers.
And then with the Chinese food,
I was so full of salt.
I grabbed a slice of Pecan Pie,
put whipped cream on the top of it
and shove that down my pie hole.
And then for the rest of the night for
no reason that I could explain medically
my face was hot.
I was like,
I was walking around,
nothing embarrassing was happening,
but I felt like I was embarrassed.
Maybe it was, I was embarrassed about
what the fuck I was eating. And then,
then the fucking kicker is I then went
out and did stand up and I'm on stage
with a hot face feeling doing my standup
and basically a walking sugar coma.
And um, so yesterday I decided, I'm like,
you know, I got to get out in front of
this fucking thing. All right, around,
I'm going to have to roll myself down
the walk to get the mail soon. So I,
uh,
I forced myself,
I forced myself to go,
uh,
to go to this fucking place that
serves salads and that type of shit.
And I swear to God, man, that just
fucking, it breaks you like cold Turkey.
You get that stuff in you and you're
just like, oh yeah, that's right.
That's right.
So this morning I woke up,
did a quick walk around the block,
banged out a hundred pushups and 60 dips
and I'm back in the fucking game back
in the fucking game. Am I? No, not really.
I just slice a pint of whiskey
before you went to bed last night.
Fucking late doing anyways,
this is the Monday podcast.
And um,
I find it hilarious how many people get
annoyed when I sit here and talk about
food and Diet and that type of thing.
But I think it's actually
funny and it's also,
I know a lot of you guys are
going through the same shit.
And the thing that I've learned is you
have to mentally push through the shit.
You know, you have to go downstairs and
work out, you know, you've got to stop B,
you got to listen to your fucking brain,
not your body that's doing the John
Travolta sweat hogs. Give me drugs,
give me drugs. Um, anyways,
but now the construction is finally done
on my house. And last night, um, uh,
not last night.
A couple of days ago,
I was able to clean out my garage for
the first time in fucking forever.
So listen to this ship.
This is how it cleaned out the garage.
I didn't sweep around shit. I took
everything out of the fucking garage.
Everything all right. And then I went
in and I swept that thing up like um,
like you know, as much as I could
get up. Cause it's, it's just,
it's a garage,
you know,
and I had like fucking three giant
piles of like sod does, cause you know,
you have construction on your
home after like two, three days.
The construction workers, they don't
even see it as your home anymore.
It's just their place now.
They've just staked their claim and
they'll leave and fucking, you know,
coffee cups in the old ratty
sweatshirts all over the fucking place.
So they started using my garage to cut
shit up and I'm just sitting there like,
I don't give a fuck where you cut it up.
Just get the God damn job done. Right.
So I had like six months of saw dust
and shit in there. Got All of that out.
Then I brought the garden hose and
spray down the whole fucking floor.
I had gone to home depot and bought one
of those fucking squeegees that has a
giant mop handle,
right?
And then after that brought in a bucket
with soap and water and fucking mop the
whole place up and then host it
back down and squeegee it out again.
Right. Cleaned it out like
a fucking marine could eat.
You could eat off the fucking floors.
All right.
Then I brought everything back.
I had one pallet left from my fucking
DVDs and I kept that thing in case any
water gets in there and I
got rid of a bunch of Shit,
put the rest of Shit and containers.
Got It all neatly over in the corner.
Now I got to hope place
where I can work out.
The whole fucking thing is great and I'm
sitting there in the end all excited,
right? Like at the end of a fucking
beer commercial and I'm looking around,
I'm like clean fucking garage and all of
a sudden I see all the way over in the
other corner.
I see all this black shit on the wall.
I've got a white wall and I see this fuck.
It looks like a streak of Greece
in a really weird for him.
Like what the fuck is that?
How did I miss that?
So I walk over there to see what it is
and I walk up to the wall and I find out
it's like fucking 10,000 little
okay.
That came up from the foundation
when I sprayed the water.
These are the ones that
survived, you know, the great
flood or some shit. You know,
there's probably some reporter aunt
down there staying in the water with the
fucking trenchcoat reporting live,
but the rest of 'em all fucking
screwed and went up the wall.
And I just sat there looking at
him, go, what do I do now? Huh?
Okay.
Do I get raid and just complete the
fucking holocaust of this ant hill
or should I fucking,
you know,
they just fucking ants,
right? I'll just let him go.
Oh, you know what? I just
got a fucking text message.
I could have fucking predicted this.
I could have fucking predicted
this. I just let me get
this, this guy to be sorry,
we beat your patriots. I swear to God. I,
if this comes from shred and Reagan who
lives out in buffalo shred and Reagan,
those two fucking pussies,
they are the absolute worst and that
probably playing this audio right now,
giggling like a couple of school girls,
they are the absolute worst.
You're going to brag about
beating the Patriots.
Tom Brady didn't even play in
the second half. You assholes.
We had to put in our fucking
second stringer. Who Was it?
Jimmy Garafalo.
We had Janine Gruffalos,
younger brother playing quarterback
and you finally beat us.
You fucking assholes. Yeah, they're
the worst. You know what's funny?
I was actually going to compliment the
buffalo bills because they were kicking
our ass when Tom Brady was in there.
So there's a lot of ways,
if I was a buffalo bills fan, I could say
that, uh, if I was you, I'd be like, no.
You guys knew you were going to lose.
So then you did like that.
That pussy video game thing with a
person just quits and says, well,
I wasn't even trying, you
know, that fucking move. Um,
I had no idea that the, uh, the bills
had that kind of a defense. So man,
they got like two guys of course,
I don't know the fucking names. Um,
two guys that have like,
you know,
double digit stack sacks and they
had another guy had like five or six,
probably had but like nine by the end
of the game with the Patriots. But um,
you know, if they could just get
a Goddamn quarterback out there,
who's kidding, who if they, if they
weren't the buffalo bills, you know,
and I'm not saying that in a
disrespectful way, I'm just being honest.
Okay. Having been there as a fan,
I lived through all the years of,
if we weren't the New England patriots,
we would have picked the right guy.
And uh, thank God Robert Kraft came
along, who I would say is going to be,
that guy is going to be in the hall
of fame as an owner, without a doubt.
Do you realize that guys, the guy
has been there for 20 fucking years.
He's gone to the Super Bowl six times.
He's got three victories.
Yeah.
He's three coaching hires.
Our Bill Parcells Pete
Carroll and bill Belicheck.
It's getting to the point if Pete
Carroll Ha, I mean Pete Carroll,
if Robert Kraft hires you as a head coach,
that's like a automatically
a plus on your resume.
So I believe the bills
have new ownership and uh,
you know, hopefully that'll work out
for it. Cause he, I I really don't,
I don't wish ill will on any fans
unless they're just ridiculous cons.
Um, like New York Yankee fans were for
all those years where they chanted 19,
18, 1918 and all that, which I
get curse of the bay, which I get,
but then when we beat him in 2004,
they all ran and hid and none of
them would answer their fleets,
all the Yankee fans, I know none of
them would answer their fucking phones.
And then they did that. Yeah.
Bullshit. What were you go 26? You
actually made a t shirt?
26 to six.
I mean that was some Colby Bryan Shit
check does it to what is wrong with you?
Just take the loss,
you know.
Anyways. Um, so I'm
actually, uh, you know,
I was actually, that was happy for bills
fans. There's certain fans, you know,
they,
they've suffered enough.
Like what did San Diego charger
fans due to the football gods.
I hated charge your fans after the one
game I went to and was basically cause
one douche bag behind me and I realized
that was wrong because I know some other
people gone down there and
they said they had a good time.
But generally speaking,
I got to tell your fans on the west coast
and California that fucking animals,
fucking animals take it way too seriously.
You know what I mean?
Look at the shift that's happened that
people get stabbed, they get shot.
You beat up a fucking dad who's sitting
there with his two kids and now he's
brain dead.
That's the fucking west coast man animals.
Um, but I still, I don't wish any, uh,
I don't wish ill will on charge of fans.
I actually was a huge fan of that.
Back when Dan Fouts, Charlie
joiner, a west Jan left,
Caitlin and Winslow Jesus Christ, racking
my brain, chuck Muncie Louis Culture.
All right, dude. He's got
shy 16 quadrapalegic clique.
He's a poor man's John Matousek. Um, oh,
by the way, I'm all over the fucking
place today. Uh, New Year's Day,
New Year's Day, the NFL network
is running a series of, uh,
what is it? Football life, you
know, behind the jock strap,
whatever the fuck they call it. I don't
know what the fuck it's called, but,
uh, they're doing one on [inaudible]
and a, and a bunch of other people.
Warren Moon's going to be a good
one. That's, that'll be a good one.
Cause that'll deal with like racism in
the NFL and why he wasn't fucking drafted.
And he had to go to the CFL and basically
break every record 9 million times,
and then they finally let him into the
NFL and he's got to play with the fucking
Houston Oilers. One of my favorite things
Warren moon ever said was when they,
when, um, when the
Houston Oilers defense was calling the
astrodome the house of pain and they kept
saying that say in the house of Payne and
he finally said to the defense because
he was older than all of those punk
kids at that point, he goes, look,
stop fucking saying that.
Okay cause I'm the one that has to
pay the price for your shit talking.
Cause basically the other difference
would come in and be like,
oh well we'll show you what the house of
pain is and then they'd be taken extra
fucking shots at Warren Moon.
And you know, the defense,
they don't have to take any shots.
They dish out the punishment. Um,
which is why I've told you for a zillion
times, I've always hated when a, when a,
when a cornerback lights up a fucking
receiver and then stands over them like
ray rice over his fiance.
You know, it's like
the,
the fucking guy,
the wide receiver is running full speed,
jumps in the air and is looking
back in the other direction,
trying to catch a flying object.
Gee, did you lay 'em out?
You know, I dunno. I mean I like a
big hit like anybody else, but uh,
that whole standing over him like you
guys squared off touch gloves and then you
fucking knock them off.
You know,
I don't know if you want to see a great
fucking flight. Oh flight, great fun.
I should say. Sorry, I'm
all fucking full of sugar,
so I'm extra add in whatever the
fuck else I got going on here. Um,
anybody watched the a Bruins,
Columbus blue jackets game
and we lost six to two hold.
Let me tell it was a Ralph
Lauren, you know, um,
fucking Lucita fought this Guy Dalton
proud. I guess it was his third bout.
I don't know how I missed the first two,
but if you just want to
see two fucking guys,
just two warriors going at it.
I mean,
it is, it's just a fucking great fight.
And I'm not one of these guys in the end.
Cause Lou Cheech got in the last punch in,
landed on top of them.
I hate when hockey fans think
that that means it's a victory.
When Lou Cheech took a
bunch of big shots too.
It was just a fucking heavyweight bout.
Okay.
They fought during the right time of
the game. They didn't hurt either team.
It was just a fucking old school.
Two heavyweights just beaten the shit.
I mean it was, it was fucking amazing.
I felt like less of a man watching it,
you know,
it's curl on my knees up into my chest,
Jesus of hitting each other so hard. Um,
that was fucking awesome.
So I'm going to uh,
definitely post the link to the one
from that I just watched last night.
Um, I tape all the Bruins
games and sometimes, uh,
there's something else on it.
I can only take so much shit
cause I have the old school.
You can only take two things at once.
So it was a little bit behind, but I'll,
I'll have all three of those
back to the future. One,
two and three with the [inaudible].
Man, it's, I'm not album.
I'm saying that guy's name,
right?
I'll say Dalton because I don't want to
disrespect the man. Uh, water. Fuck it.
I'm just a fucking great
fight. Awesome. Um,
why wasn't I watching the
Bruins verse the Blue Jackets?
Because I started watching Boston
college versus Penn state in the,
uh, looking up your skirt bowl,
whatever the fuck they were playing in.
It was something really weird. The
pen and pencil set bull. I mean,
it's one of the fucking, you
know, one of those fucking bowls.
So we're in this guy damn thing.
We got these fuckers beat.
They can't move the
ball. 21 seven. We're up.
It's fucking over their quarterback.
You know,
he rolls it back. You know,
looking like a fuck it,
it's got that good looking
Gerber baby face going on, right.
He throws the ball right at our defensive
back. The guy goes to slap it down.
He tips it up in the fucking
Penn state guy catches a 2114.
Oh,
this was the night I had the four beers.
That fucking dumplings in the piece
of Pie. So I kind of blacked out.
I want the fuck happened.
The sugar, salt coma.
Next thing I know it's 2121 goes into
overtime and my good friend Paul Versey
hates the extra point.
He wants to get rid of the extra point
or cause he think he's like, dude,
it's so fucking stupid.
They make it 99.9% of the time.
And I'm sitting there going, yeah,
but it's the times that they miss it.
That makes it worth it because
it's so fucking dramatic. And uh,
that's what happened in fucking bit
me in the ass this time as a fan.
Fucking BC goes down over time,
gets the ball in,
poses their wealth.
Let's their presence be known or whatever
fucking sports cliche you want to
fucking hear about.
They go down,
score a touchdown and their kicker goes
out and basically he fucking hook this
thing so bad. I can't believe he didn't
hit himself in the face with the ball.
Was he a lefty?
Maybe.
I don't know what the fuck if he shanked
it or whatever the fuck you want to
call it. He misses the thing.
So we only get six points.
All right.
The fucking Penn state gets the ball
and then they just drive right down the
field.
They score a touchdown and then kick the
fucking next to point and then they're
fucking kicker starts running down the
field. Like he just kicked a 70 yard,
which made it even more painful to watch.
Here's my question.
I just realized as I was telling
that story, I thought it,
if you scored a touchdown
and overtime it was over,
but if you kicked a field goal,
the other team got to have like
equal amount of possessions.
Wasn't that how it was or is it always
you, you know you get equal possessions
or is it you at least
get one possession each?
I can't fucking remember cause I was
just trying to think. There was a,
because we missed the extra point
that they got the blood pressure,
you get equal possessions. I
don't fucking know. So whatever.
So I made fun of that Penn state guy
running, or they're just, you know, just,
I didn't make fun of the guy. And
somebody writes, writes to me on Twitter,
I'm man wrote this to me.
He wrote, um, dot. Dot.
He's only like
the best field goal kicker
in college football.
Dude, a grown man wrote,
um, dot. Dot. Dot.
I can't stand these fucking guys on
Twitter that tweet like fucking preteen
girls.
Jesus fucking Christ I and,
and what,
what's wrong with me that,
that fucking annoys me that much and
I have to make that point to him. I,
you know what? I'm the
asshole. Fuck that guy.
If you want to go on like maybe next
time. Wait, what? If you want to do that?
Go ahead and fucking, I'm, you know, I'm
gonna try to be less of a cut in 2015.
All right, but it's only December 29th.
So I got another two days of this shit,
so fucking get used to it. All
right, let's do a little, uh,
a little advertise in here.
Uh, live reads old Geez issue.
Um, oh look who's back here.
Dollar Shave club, everybody.
Can someone tell me when razors got so
God damn expensive and if I been asleep
for nearly 20 years,
I was in a store the other day and one
pack of razors is now 20 bucks one pack.
That's crazy. But Hey, sometimes
they give you a free gift. A,
when you buy their overpay,
a overpriced rages,
which is actually just
a punch in the Dick.
I like a dollar shave club doesn't
even wait for you to start cursing.
They just start doing it. Well, I guess
I could drop f bombs at this point.
Don't get beat up by the
fucking razor prices. Everybody.
The ridiculous razor prices gets
you get your shave gear where um,
millions of people get theirs from Dollar
Shave club.com for just a few bucks a
month.
Dollar Shave club.com delivers amazing
razors and other great grooming supplies
right to your doorstep.
There plan starts at just $3
$3 a homeless person could,
could get raises.
All right.
Now I don't know if you've
noticed a lot of homeless people.
I'll look at a lot more babyface this day.
Share. They still smell like excrement,
but that's not the point of this copy.
Here's how it works.
They send you the handle for free and
every month they send you a replacement
blades. It's one less thing
you got to worry about.
You can get deliveries every month or
every other month or however the hell you
want to do it. They've got a lot
of other grooming supplies too.
You know I that I love
their one wipe Charlies.
Why pay 20 bucks for a razor when you
can get a fantastic shave from dollar
shave club for a fraction of the price?
Stop getting smacked around
by high razor prices.
Dollar Shave club.com razors are great
and they're a fraction of the price.
Trust me, you'll wish you
had done it sooner. Don't be
a dumb ass. Shapes smarter.
Go to dollar shave club.com/burr.
That's dollar shave club.com/burr
dollar shave club.com/burr.
All right. Draft Kings, draft kings.com
everybody, the list of millionaires,
crown head wrap,
kings.com this football season keeps
on rolling and you could be next or you
could go broke. All right. If
you're a degenerate gambler,
can I actually have some sort of like,
you know,
don't put your month's rent on this.
Have Fun with this.
Draft Kings is a fun place to be. Don't
turn it into a nightmare. All right,
your daughter's going to need
braces in a few years. Okay,
go easy on that cowboys bet.
All right.
Draft Kings is America's favorite one
week fantasy football site where you can
win instant catch right there every week
and the beauty of one week fantasy as
you play whenever you want every week.
It's like a brand new season.
It takes watching football
to a whole new level.
Your season long fantasy team
might be missing the playoffs,
but the excitement begins again each
and every week@draftkings.com pick your
team and minutes and enormous
cash prizes could be yours.
They might not be, but
they could be. True. Story.
One player turns 10 grand into five
another turn two bucks into 10,000 another
person lost his entire life savings.
That's what's not in this copy.
Don't be a moron with this thing.
This is a fun place to go.
And I know millionaire has been made
every week this season at draft kings dat
count another guy's out sucking dick.
No,
you gotta get in on this.
Head over to draftkings.com right now
and use Promo code defense to play free
and the $10 million fantasy
football world championships,
draftkings.com bigger events, bigger
winnings, bigger millionaires.
Enter defense now@draftkings.com
draftkings.com that's draftkings.com enter
defense. All right. You know
what? Only got one more.
Why don't we get these out of the way?
The old classic, the old bottom bitch,
stamps.com everybody.
One great resolution,
one great resolution you
can make for the new year.
Maximize every minute and every
dollar for your small business.
I know an easy way to do that.
where@stamps.com think about how much
time you're wasting going to the post
office. I'll give you a second
to think about it. You're done.
Good driving. They're finding parking,
standing behind that smelly old person.
stamps.com is a way better way to get
postage. Just use what you already have.
Your computer and printer
to get official use.
Not Use your official US postage
for any letter or package.
Then the mail man picks it up with
stamps.com everything you would do at the
post office you can do right at your
desk and at a fraction of the cost of one
of those expensive postits meters.
I've been using stamps.com I don't
even know for like two, three years.
It's gotta be going on three
years to send out all my posters.
Anything I'm going to whore myself out
with at the end of my show selling them.
I'm a moron if I can, if I can
figure out how to do it. So can you.
It's very convenient right now.
Use My last name,
bur bur to get this special offer,
no risk trial plus a $110 bonus offer
that includes a digital scale and up to
$55 free postage. Don't wait. Go to
stamps.com before you do anything else,
click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com
enter
burr are right.
So what else I want to talk about here?
I cleaned out the garage. Oh, here's,
here's a weird thing I had this morning,
right?
I fucking um,
okay.
I uh, somebody delivered, they,
somebody delivered a package,
ever get a package and it's not for you,
it's for somebody else,
but they live on the same number.
Like you live on one, two,
three Smith Street and they live
on one, two, three Allen Street.
And it's like fucking, uh, you know,
it's like a mile away or something.
And I'm thinking I could, you know
what, what am I going to do here?
I could fucking,
you know,
I could fucking just give this to the
post office person, right. And be like,
this doesn't belong to us.
You take it, but then what?
It's December 29th when you think
this person's going to get it.
Once it goes back into the systems system,
all those fucking maniacs down there,
this guy's going to get this thing or
this lady is going to get this thing after
New Year's Day. Alright, I
Google search the person's house.
I've done this like three fucking times.
Um,
I've actually gotten in my car and just
driven it over to the person's house.
And then there's always that weird
point is you're walking up there,
walk thinking like, am I
going to get shot? And they're
always psyched. You know,
the first time I did it,
I walked up and the lady came walking
out of the house and I got freaked out.
I was just like, Hey, they
accidentally delivered this
to my house. She was like, oh
right.
That's what she did.
Then she just froze just like that.
And I kinda like moved my hand in front
of him and she just was like catatonic.
She was so fucking happy. Then I skipped
back to my Prius and I drove away.
And that's the end of that story. So
anyways, I, uh, so I'm like, all right,
I'm going on a fucking walk this morning.
Good to try to walk off some
of the whiskey and pie I
ate right before I went to
sleep. Fucking pig and a, I'll bring
it over to this person's house.
I see. It's like two fucking miles away.
Am I going two miles over, two miles back?
There's a four or five mile walk, if
you know, whatever, that's good thing.
Burn off some calories.
So I fucking walk over to this place
and uh,
it's a little ways up
into the hills and shit.
And I get there and it turns out it's
like a gated community and I got this
stupid fucking box and I'm like,
what am I going to do
in the fucking house?
Was like one house into the gated
community. So I'm like, well,
what do I do? I can't leave
it at the gate. I don't want,
I'll fucking walk this
thing all the way back.
Do I throw it over the fence and
try to get it to the driveway?
What if this is broken it?
Then I just looked and they had like
they had the defense went like across the
street and then there was a brick wall
with a ledge on it and
the fence went up on that
and I was just like, you know what?
I could be up and over this thing,
drop off the package and backup and
over before even has a chance to call
anybody. I don't want to lug this
fucking thing back. So then by myself,
I start laughing like a schoolgirl.
I'm looking for cameras.
I don't see any, and I'm
like, this is fucking so
fucking climbed up over it and my
heart's racing. I'm already rehearsing.
What I'm going to say to the cop?
Well what two three [inaudible] street?
This was for a kid
like, you know, am I going to
get arrested for this shit?
I got this fucking like ridiculous
stupid Bruins sweatshirt on.
That's like black. It's not even gold.
Like I think it's like a knock off.
It's like yellow almost.
You could spot me a million miles away
and I'm on foot if anybody calls the cops.
But I did it,
dropped it off right back up and over.
The whole thing took like maybe fucking
20 seconds and I walked away laughing
and rehearsing what I was going to
say to the cop and nothing happens.
And so they go and you know what,
that's my good deed for the day.
My good deed for the day.
So they got,
don't ever let gay communities
a fucking hilarious and the most
okay,
they look, there's nobody guarding it.
That's what I realized is just a fence.
And then you got these people who are
too dumb to become a police officer,
you know, you know, too
lazy to walk around a mall.
They just want to sit in a truck.
What are they doing?
They were rubbing their
balls and they're on Twitter.
They're not paying attention.
I literally could have taken
that fence down, you know,
and just dragged it over to home
depot and sold it from metal scrap.
I think it would still take two
hours before anybody even showed up.
I lost all respect for gated communities,
gated community.
The fuck are you doing in there? How
you're sacrificing virgins. You know
how fucking crook I could see like look,
okay,
I shouldn't say this, but I think only
women should live in gated communities.
Like if you're like a pop star and you
have like a fucking stalker and shit,
you know, you should be behind
them. But I think if you're a man,
you should fight your stalker right
in your front yard. Kick his ass,
running your front lawn.
You know,
fun kid. That's actually a
dangerous subject to talk
about. I'm fucking with you.
Um, AH, Jesus. Blame it on the pie bill.
Oh, I want to thank all the cons.
Who sent me shit because another,
a Singapore airline a is now missing. You
know, putting that in my fucking head.
Like, are you, aren't you
afraid to go over there? Now?
Actually know what the odds,
the odds are pretty fucking good.
You know,
odds are pretty good
that they just lost one.
I don't even hit me with that fucking,
uh,
rules of three's a.
So my fucking buddy to a
Michigan Fan texting me here.
I think the news is milking it while
Michigan and harbor is being considered to
the niners players. I'll lean
into, okay, Jim Harbaugh,
ball ball, ball, ball, ball, ball ball.
Oh is the only way to
play drums to that shit.
Door. Door. Door. The door.
All right. Classic White fucking beat.
You fucking clap on all four beats.
Clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap,
clap, clap, clap, clap, clap, clap,
clap,
clap.
Where? Fuck and white. And
we bought some to buzz today.
Um, you might be going to
the University of Michigan,
which should be great for the big 10,
whatever.
And they know they got
like 15 fucking teeth now.
That would be great for the big 10.
It is not good for the big 10.
When Michigan's not good. You Need
Ohio state and Michigan to be good.
You need them to beat the fuck out
of each other. And then you know,
everybody else falls in the
line. I'm sorry, Michigan State.
I'm sorry. Wisconsin. Alright.
Wisconsin. You had your day,
you went to three fucking rose bowls in
a row and you did a great impression of
the early nineties buffalo bills.
Okay. I want it to you guys to win.
I was rooting for you.
When you play tacy you come on frogs and
you know what you did? You fucked me.
You fucked me three years in a row.
Yeah.
All right, so it's going to be a long
while before I, I root for that fucker.
Giant red w again.
Okay.
Even though we've got a good now the
badgers, that's a great fucking name.
I don't hate Wisconsin. I was just
fucking sick of watching them coming in.
They're all fucking cheesy and pasty and
all that cheesy pasty fucking fans and
they just walking out with their
heads hanging down low, you know.
Okay.
Sitting there with a handful of fucking
blue cheese in one hand and some fucking
Cheddar and the other,
you know,
dabbin their cheers with some
tears with some Kraft slices.
Oh Geez. Um, all right. So, you know
what a lot of people told me that, uh,
they'd rather listen to me
talk about music then sports.
So I figured I'd talk about
sports for 35 fucking minutes.
I also talked about food. I go, fuck
yourself. Start Your own podcast. Um,
I finally had some downtime and old law.
Okay.
Oh, Billy boy here is uh,
got back into playing drums.
I want to do another one of those
goddamn comedy jams coming up.
So I'm working on a song,
can't say which song it is,
but it has double bass in it.
And old Billy is not a double bass player.
So, um, I've actually been, uh,
I've been woodshedding as they say,
I'm playing drums trying to get it down.
And I mean, I don't know. I was
one of those fucking assholes.
I just totally got way into John Bonham
when I was playing and my brothers both
played guitar and they weren't into
Metallica and that type of shit.
And they were like, get a double pedal,
get a double bass, get another bass drum.
Let's fucking do that. And I, I kind
of look back, wished I did, but, um,
I didn't play it because, uh, I dunno,
I had this competitive fucking thing and
Bonham's bass drum foot was faster than
mine and I was like,
I'm not getting a double bass
pedal until I can play good times,
bad times with a single
base drum pedal and
okay.
And this is like back,
you know, this is the 80s,
so I have no help.
I have to just basically listened to
the record of the tape and try to figure
out what he's doing as
opposed to all the kids today.
You can just fucking go on youtube and
there'll be some 20 year pro show you
that slide step fucking
thing. I had no idea, man.
I was fucking my foot up trying to
figure out how the hell he was doing it.
Right. So anyways, I started,
I know I didn't play drums for like 10
years when I started doing comedy and I
moved to New York City's,
you know,
drums that you can't like strum a fucking
set of drums in your apartment in New
York. Trust me. So, um,
I didn't play until, uh,
I got more established as a comedian.
I was able to afford one of those
electronic drum kits, the, uh,
the Roland ones, which were fucking
amazing then forget about now.
And I'm thinking about getting
another one just for in the house,
so I won't drive me nuts.
But, uh, was I gonna say,
so I remembered how I just got so
obsessed with John Bonham that it really
affected my plank.
Cause I just sounded like another
guy who just listened to bond them.
And then all the players that were
into were derivative of John Bonham.
So then I would have just go
back to his playing again.
I just couldn't get out
of this fucking vortex.
It just listening to the same fucking guy.
So I went out and I bought a
double pedal like 10, 12 years ago,
that DW 5,000, you know what the
red plate on the bottom. And, um,
I go, you know, I was listening
to the Primus and I got, you know,
listen to old Metallica and I tried to
get into it and I gave it a shot and I
went right back to the bottom thing.
And um,
but made sure that I expanded what
I listened to, uh, since then.
But uh, so I've dusted this
fucking thing off. I mean,
I still have it in the case. I
got all this, all the attachments,
all of that Shit I've made sure like,
like hate when people sell stuff,
all musical equipment and they fucking,
they don't have all the
original shit to it. You know,
like even my truck, I got this
old truck and you know, they,
the radiators back then ran a little hot.
So, uh, then aluminum runs run better.
So put a new aluminum one
in and I kept the old one.
And when we switched out the front brakes,
I went from drum to disc.
I still kept the drum brakes,
actually learned how to put
those fucking things together.
I bought all the tools in that shit
and I kept all of it. You know,
had somebody put a new rear
end in it and uh, I fucking,
I have all of the, I have all those
parts. I kept all of that shit.
I have the old masters cylinder.
So anyways, I've been, um,
I've been playing a lot
of double bass right now
and this song is actually,
if you're double bass player is
actually a simple song to play,
but if he'd never played it,
it's just so fucking weird.
So I've been literally just
sitting there, uh, you know,
60 bpms ticket ticket ticket,
ticket back and ticket ticket,
ticket ticket to get the
good, take a packet, they get
thicker, thicker, 70 digging,
digging, digging, digging, development.
I can't play it that fast, but whatever,
just trying to work my way up.
So the songs at about 115 bpms and I'm
about up to like 95 and I got two weeks
to go. So, uh, I went
to a Mike's lessons.com.
Um, he doesn't play double based too much
shit on that, but you know, he's got,
it's just the best site.
It's just as far as his practice,
like that technique where it's a,
see,
this is why I don't talk fucking drums
in that type of shit cause I know it
right now.
Everybody's just fucking so I feel like
I'm teaching like geography right now.
I don't know where. Um, but if you're a
drummer out there, Mike's lessons.com,
I cannot recommend it highly enough.
Um,
and you want to talk about God
with a sick fucking bass drum foot.
He's fucking unbelievable. Um,
so anyways, and you know what?
This actually gets me, somebody asked me
about what I, what I thought about, um,
what I thought about whatever that
fucking movie was, where the uh,
whiplash, here we go. Let's do
some questions here. Uh, dear bill,
hope he had a great holiday and I loved
the show. Thank you. My question is,
have you seen the film whiplash?
It's about a student and a
music conservatory trying
to become the next great
jazz drummer.
A Jk Simmons plays his
music teacher slash.
Mentor, but the movie flips around
all the usual music, movie tropes.
Simmons acts more like a drill sergeant
and screams and intimidates the students
to push them further.
I don't want to say much more
because the movie speaks for itself,
but I know you'll love it.
Especially given your affinity for drums.
The movie also raises a
more general question.
Are the all time greats in any field
born or can they be made thoughts?
Um, Eh, great fucking question. Um,
I thought what's his face?
Jk Simmons was unbelievable in that movie.
Uh,
but I love drums.
So watching him scream and yell at
somebody who also loved drums was like,
I kinda had a hard time watching it.
It'd be like if I was watching a movie
about standup and there was somebody
screaming at some open Miker, I'd
be like, he didn't do it, you know,
fucking do that. You
encourage, you know? Um,
but I mean, I still think, I still thought
it was, it was a really good movie,
but I would actually say the best drums,
uh,
the best drums in any movie
this year is not in whiplash.
The best rooms in any movie by far that I,
I,
that I saw was in a birdman.
Birdman has sick drums in it and it then,
they're not even as difficult technically
as the drawing that was in whiplash,
but it's dynamics.
Dynamics will take your playing over the
fucking top if you know how to utilize
them, which I do not put whoever the
fuck played the drums on the, uh,
Birdman soundtrack was
fucking unbelievable,
was that he's just one of those guys sits
down at a four piece kit and just gets
more music out of that than I could have
fucking Terry Bozzio that's inspiring
and frustrating and it's just like,
Eh,
that's why I became a comedian because
I can't fucking do that. All right,
so you asked me,
um,
are the all time greats in any field
born or can they be made thoughts?
I think both.
Um,
I think everybody is born with a talent
and then it's up to you to try to see
how far it's all up to you,
how far you want to take it.
And I think that a lot of,
yeah,
a lot of the greats,
a lot of the times are
not necessarily the best,
uh,
weren't blessed with the most talent.
It's just that they had
that brutal combination of blessed with
enough of the gift and they had drive to
try to get themselves as
great as they could get in.
A lot of times when people are born
with a fucking ridiculous gift,
it comes easy to them and
they'll, they'll coast. Um,
and that's what made Jordan so great
because Jordan was like born with like the
greatest talent of all,
but worked like he was born with my gift
for playing basketball and that's why
he became the greatest who ever fucking
plate or like a Jerry Rice or something
like that. And um, so I would say
it's a combination of both. So,
you know, I dunno, whatever
your fucking talent is,
you should be always trying to just
compete against yourself and then then you
won't become like this bitter asshole.
Cause you don't wanna compete against
somebody else cause they were born with a
different gift than you. You know what I
mean? And then you'll, you'll try to like,
uh,
you know,
that happens in my fucking business where
like you get an acting gig and you'll
do a scene and somebody is
trying to out like act you.
I was just talking about somebody talking
to somebody about this like last night,
the train like out at you being like, it's
like, no, dude, we're in this together.
You don't, let's fucking do
this thing together. So, um,
yeah.
Does that make any sense?
I feel like just went from a fucking
funny podcast to a Goddamn lecture for the
last 10 minutes.
Let's talk about talents every bloody.
Are you born with it or is it,
is it made from your hard work?
Today we're going to talk to two people.
Both who chronically jerk off one
person since the day he was born,
the crib, the other person who did not
discover masturbating until he was 23.
Mark and Chris,
welcome to the program.
Um, all right, let's get on to the
next one here. Uh, oh, Rex Ryan.
Happy trails to you.
Bunch of people got fired today.
Uh, wait a minute. That's PTI. I just
ripped off to PTI show. Sorry man.
See that's why I don't watch other
comedians cause it fucking just sticks in
your head. And next thing you know, you
say some shit that they were saying.
All right. Uh, Rex Ryan, he got fired. Uh,
I don't know how I feel about that.
I guess they just,
they just been together long enough
so they had to make the move. I mean,
I think that guy is,
he's a bit of a knucklehead.
Okay.
You know,
very crass.
He's not a dumb guy,
but he just,
he's got that low self esteem thing that
he just walks around and just has to
act like a dope.
I don't know why he does that
because I think he's a great coach.
And um,
I think he was a victim of a
bad GM that John, what was it?
His Dick [inaudible] fuck you
goddamn name. I mean that guy just,
he made some moves and they
didn't fucking pan out. Right.
You got rid of fucking Reavis,
although you've got a number one draft
pick in that panned out. But then like,
I dunno, they had all these draft picks
and they used all of them. I was, I mean,
I'm just fucking
regurgitate and what I read,
I mean it seemed to be
when rex had the players,
he got him to the fucking
AFC championship game.
Then all of a sudden all
the players were taken away.
What the fuck are you going to do?
Right?
Every fucking great coach.
He got to have the players.
So I think that that guy would be a
great pickup and now I'm actually hoping
that he goes to the NFC.
I don't because I have,
I'm just like, I'm sick of it. I
just don't, I don't, I don't know.
There's something about that guy. I Dunno.
She's been wanting, I watched that jets,
one of the fucking inside the locker room
whenever the fuck it was and he's like,
hey, we can beat any fucking team in
this league. It was just like this.
That's how you talk to your team.
Look far be it from me
to talk about the f bomb.
But there's a time and a place for it,
right.
You just going to casually
use that word and then what,
what are you going to do when you
blow a gasket? What the fuck was that?
It's just you. You've already done that.
But a fuck. It was like Mike Smith.
Mike Smith never looked
like a head coach to me.
He always looked like somebody
who like infiltrated the mob.
How's he know what I mean?
He sort of looks like he's in the mob
and he also kind of looks like a cop.
He just be the perfect guy for the cops
to try to get in the infiltrate and try
to break it up. Hey,
break it up. Okay. Um,
yeah.
Who else? That guy, Marc
Trestman, Jim Harbaugh,
a bunch of guys lost their
fucking jobs. Um, so anyways,
whatever, who gives a fuck my
bill? ESPN here, by the way,
people, it is three days away from the
granddaddy of them all in this year.
It's a fucking playoff game. FSU
versus fucking Oregon. And this year,
last year, if you guys, if
you've been listening for the,
for a while last year, uh,
old freckles here passed out at the
tailgate. That's how hard I went.
So this year I'm actually,
I'm going to try to enjoy it.
I'm going to try to live in the moment,
but I, I say that every fucking year.
Yeah.
Oh man, I can't fucking wait.
We're doing ribs this year.
We got some burgers.
We're actually bringing a power strip
with a generator because the second that
game's over,
we're coming back out.
We're firing back up the grill and we're
going to sit there freezing our asses
off watching the fucking
Alabama game, uh, bleary eyed.
Um,
I can't fucking wait and
I'm going to try to go easier.
Yeah.
Last year I got a little
drunk and belligerent.
Remember yelling at some fucking idiot.
That was a fucking idiot last year.
So I really got to, I got to tone it down.
Oh, I never finished talking about it.
Some of you talked about me going
to Singapore and all that, like,
can you give me a favorite,
a fucking send me tweets about
me dying in a plane crash.
Yukons and how do I
fucking do that to you?
Do I fucking write to you and ask
you if you fucking dreams died?
I don't do that to you.
Um,
and fuck all you douchebags and think
you're now clever that you're going to do
it. It's like, that's some amazing,
God damn joke it out. I don't know.
I fucking,
who did I see doing something like that.
Okay.
Oh, did you guys see that Twitter fight
with a dude? Actually, those guys, they,
they could greed to fight.
They were arguing over Koby
Bryant and they agreed to fight.
So one of the guys shows up to the fight
and the other guy wasn't even in the
state.
And then he does like
this interview about it.
Like what he did was amazing
that he agreed to fight this guy.
And then he didn't show up like
this was some massive fucking,
okay.
You know,
he's like this genius burglar that
figured out how to break into the fucking
Federal Reserve. It's like,
dude, all you did was lie.
You're a pussy.
I,
that's one thing about fucking the
Internet that drives me up the wall is how
trolls feel like they're
fucking like these. Uh,
okay.
I Dunno like the, these geniuses
and it's just like, dude,
you're doing the lowest
common denominator of a,
okay.
I Dunno. I don't know what the
fuck to call the art. I don't know.
It's like a shit joke. Not
that I'm against shit jokes,
but I just didn't know.
Why is this guy like you,
this guy challenge you to fight.
You said you're going to go there and
you didn't go and then you talking about
yourself like you some sort of bad ass.
Like, yeah, I pissed off a of people.
This is the first
time ever got anybody show up to five.
All right. Well he showed up
and he was ready to fight.
I think I'd rather hang out
with that other guy. Then you,
you fucking passive aggressive
little pansy. All right. Anyways,
response to your advice last week
about guy into girl with the laugh.
Like his friend.
All right,
so those of you didn't listen last week
there was this dude who met this uh,
woman. She's beautiful. She had a
great rack, great rack as he said,
and uh, they hit it off. She was
awesome. And everything was great.
She was great in the rain, the bed,
everything was fucking awesome.
Everything is coming up roses and then
the only thing was that she laughed
exactly like his friend and
that was weird and I'm out,
so here we go. Okay. In response
to a, my advice to that person,
he said last week you talked,
you talked, read an email.
Can you guys please fucking,
you know I suck at reading.
Can you just please proof read
what you wrote. All right.
Last week you read an email about a guy
who was worried about dating a girl with
a laugh like her brother.
You acknowledged that the advice you
were giving was probably not the greatest
when you said that it would be
brutal to have to live with that.
I'm writing to tell you that you are
correct. Correct in saying you're wrong.
In my opinion, in my opinion, that is
no matter what girl you meet and date,
she'll have characteristics of a male
family member he described. Yeah,
but dude, this is the
thing. It was his friend
and he knew his friend
for whatever years and years and years
hanging out with them as this Sharon
laughs. You know what I mean? I'm
not saying like, you know, oh,
you meet a girl and she has her dad's
eyes or something. Yeah, they're a family.
They can,
she's also going to look like our mom.
This is all getting weird Friday in
here anyways. No matter what a girl,
what girl you meet and date,
she'll have the characteristics
of male family members.
He described the girl to be hot,
quirky and fun and she was into him.
She didn't make it awkward when
hooking up. She sounded awesome.
If anything he should bring it out in
the open and teller. How weird it is. Oh,
toad.
I don't know about that one.
Then when they laugh about
it and she does the laugh,
they're laughing about the laughter.
Laughing about that laugh even more.
Huh?
Takes his dick out.
I don't see how that works.
I'm really trying to see your point here,
sir. Hey, I could be wrong. Um, anyways.
Then when they laugh about it.
Oh yeah. I already said that. Uh,
it'll go beyond the awkward situation,
become its own inside joke.
Plus if she likes him,
that's a terrible way for her to be
rejected just for laughing naturally.
I know you weren't being a Dick and
have to make America laugh, have a week,
but I just want this guy, I just don't
want this guy to blow it. All right.
See you coming from a good place.
Um,
okay.
Don't you think what you're going
to say?
Okay.
Is going to make her self conscious.
Like I,
I want you write me back again and you
tell me how you're going to tell her. Hey,
by the way,
when you laugh you laugh just like your
brother and that weirds me out in the
Dick area.
Like
that's kind of what you saying even
though you're not going to be that blunt
about it.
Um,
yeah.
I don't know how the eff or somebody else,
somebody else right in and tell me
exactly how you pull that off because
everything else you said about the woman.
I agree with that shit.
That's just a rough one. That one. I,
you just could picture myself
just out in the kitchen,
cutting up some shit for
a sandwich or something.
And then she laughs in the other room
and then you just sort of fucking wince.
You know,
she's in there talking to a friends,
laughing it up and you just sat in the
kitchen. You talk and he saw how I got it.
It sounds, it sounds just
like Scott. It's fucking,
I believe a block it up,
blah blah. Hey ladies,
would you like some cheese nips,
cheese nips. Greetings from Mexico.
Um,
I discovered you the other night while
browsing Netflix all by myself and I just
thought my two team and husband boys
15 and 16 have got to watch this.
So we did. I totally fell in
love with you. Smart comedy,
great points of view and I really find
you totally educational for teens.
Um,
did you watch my special or did
you watch a Ted talk anyways?
So if you did decide to either
adopt or have your kids of your own,
you're going to do great. Ps. I've
already started to hug my kids less.
Let's hope it's not too late. No Homo,
no homophobia here. Lol. All right,
look at that.
I got a fan down in Mexico.
MMM.
Yeah. A lot of people telling me
I should adopt. You should do it.
You should go out there and fucking do
it. Uh, we'll see. We'll see what I do.
I have to say, as I often feel, I'm too,
too out of my mind too fucking scatter
brain in two fucking selfish to do
something like that.
To have kids.
Okay.
Yeah. There's fucking 7 billion
people on the planet, you know,
running out of deer and fresh water.
What the fuck are we doing?
You know,
I don't know. Anyways, uh, from
Russia with go fuck yourself.
I ah,
Shit.
I almost didn't get that
from Russia with love. No.
From Russia with go fuck
yourself. All right, here we go.
Hello Bill.
Okay.
It will be a strange message.
First of all, I want to thank you.
I love Russian. So just
fucking, I must break you.
It will be a message that is strange.
First of all,
I want to thank you for
your incredible craft.
Can I call comedy a craft
and for your podcast? Dude,
I want to compliment you on your
incredible English. Are you a spy?
This is unbelievable.
Anyway, I am from Russia.
Then I have to say that we love you here.
Get the fuck Outta here.
I'll do a show in Moscow.
I'm going to show up with no
money in my fucking passport.
Laugh locked in a fucking
safe back in the hotel room.
Okay?
I'm not going to get rolled in. Moscow.
Moscow was a shady fucking place.
That's the word. It's
beautiful. It's gorgeous,
but you will get knocked
the fuck out in Russia.
Wake up in a vodka plant.
Your job's to put the cork in them for
the rest of your fucking life and they
don't give you,
they don't give you any mittens anyways,
even with the crazy things.
Maybe a, wait a minute. Wait.
Where the fuck at me second.
I'm from Russia and we have
to say, we love you here.
Really?
It's even,
it even freaks me out when I realized
that I agree on 100% with what you're
saying. Even with the crazy
things. Maybe not with all of them,
but it's amazing because even we have
different cultures as some may say,
I can relate myself to all your topics,
women, marriage, dogs, politics, idiots,
et cetera. Yeah. You know, why
do cause work gear, human being,
all that other stuff is just a,
okay,
that's just all of the bullshit.
So every country is full of shit
except maybe New Zealand,
our country like that.
That doesn't really fuck with anybody.
He just kind of stay down
there and live their life,
you know?
But other than that,
everybody else did just spin it.
And there
the leaders just say that everything
that your country is doing is fucking
heroic and you're in the right.
But at the end of the day,
both countries got a bunch of broads and
the drive and the guys up the fucking
wall there. Um, and whatever the guys
who are driving the women, that's,
that's what I learned.
Traveling the world.
All right.
There's a through line with human beings
and it's basically watching your friend
fall down a flight of stairs
is the funniest fucking
thing you're ever going to
see. I don't give a fuck
what country you're from.
I don't give a fuck if you're in such a
poor country that they don't even have
stairs.
If he just ran out of his hut,
stop quickly and it rained and he slipped
and banged the back of his head and
then he curls up in the fetal
position with both hands.
Clasping the back of his head.
You're going to fucking
laugh for the whole morning.
Okay.
Anyways, he says, uh,
I hope politicians were turned off
the heat between our countries.
It will be great for everyone.
Yeah. Except for big business. Um,
don't believe in all this
bullshit about hatred. Personally,
I don't have nothing against the
United States. It's a great country.
What a country quoting
Yakov, Smirnoff, uh,
beautiful nature and kindhearted people,
fast cars and blues music.
Lots of problems of course,
but we have them to, uh,
everyone has nice to see this
fucking guy's enlightened. Exactly.
Hope you'll come to Russia someday.
You know what's funny is this.
If he actually fucking hates
me and now just buttering me up
and I go over there and he puts a fucking
potato sack over my head and beats me
with a mic stand, I'd actually
find the humor in that beat down.
Good day to you and
best wishes. Ps. Sorry,
I've made some mistakes
and text in the text.
I'm still in the process of
learning. I'll fuck you. Fuck you.
You asshole. I know what you're
doing. You know what's your, your,
your English is great and you know we
can't speak any other languages over here
that was passive aggressive.
You know what, sir,
I fucking loved you to that last sentence.
You know what?
Now I think you aren't going to jump
me when I go over there, but really,
you know what? Let me hear it from more,
more people in Russia. If I can get,
what do I need?
What do I need to go over there?
Just get me like 400 fucking
people. If you can, you can.
If you can guarantee
me 400 fucking people,
400 people will fucking show
up to my show in Moscow.
All right.
And I won't get a pinky sliced off or
any sort of fucking black mart market.
Mafioso shit going on down there.
I will come over there.
All right. And like I said, I am showing
up there with the shirt on my back,
nothing else.
This is all based on a cab ride
I took when I was in Helsinki,
Finland and I was asking him about
Lithuania and Estonia and all these other
things and I was like, yeah man, it's
crazy fucking Russia's like right there,
you know, talking about
growing up with the, you know,
all that Cold War shit. And,
and he was saying, you know,
he was saying Moscow is a beautiful
place, but it's fucking shady. He said,
after 5:00 PM it goes, it
gets fucking shady. He goes,
I'm not saying it's a bad place,
but you really have to watch
yourself after five o'clock.
And it's just like, oh,
all right. So it's a,
it's like Detroit. Um,
but there's something about getting
your ass kicked in another country.
It's way scarier because
you have no fucking idea.
I would think as you're fighting going,
like what if I end up in a Goddamn jail,
you know?
Yeah.
And everybody is speaking a different
fucking language. I mean, that's just,
that's just spells ass rate to me.
Um, all right. Cubans in America,
this is the last thing and then I got to
get rolling here. Uh, Cubans in America.
Bill,
what are your thoughts on normalizing
relations with Cuba in the United States?
Um,
well I think
honestly, I think, uh, we've been
bullying him for fucking 50 years.
They have a right to fucking run
their country they way they want to.
I'm not saying Castro is a
great fucking guy, but, uh,
I don't think what we did to them.
Look,
obviously they couldn't have
those fucking missiles there.
We had to get rid of that
shit that I agreed with. But
other than that, you know,
if they want to be communists than you.
Now, if you want to fucking do that,
go ahead and do it. I mean,
what's funny, you can go ahead.
We have nuclear weapons. What are you
going to do to us? Shoot one at us.
We'll shoot of you when it's over. It's
done. What are you a fucking idiot?
Go ahead. Be a Russian, not Russia. Sorry
to be a communist. I don't give a shit,
but I mean, you know, to be honest,
we were trying to turn that
fucking country into a,
a place for us to go there and relax
and go vacation and casinos and take all
their natural resources doing
what the fuck we always do.
And then we deal with
the whole, uh, the, they,
they don't want their people to be free,
you know,
and I'm not saying Cuba's fucking it,
uh, innocent, but come on anyways.
He says cigars could be in the future,
in the future,
could become legal in the u s as of
right now, $100 worth of tobacco.
You can bring in Cuban cigars,
which is hilarious.
It's like fucking three cigars for cigars
or whatever. He said, ah, what would you,
what would this do to the
size of your human door? Um,
I've actually shut down my humidor
because I was smoking too many of them.
Um, and he said, I know you enjoy Cubans,
but do you smoke cigars
from other regions as well?
Next time you're in Calgary,
come in the summer and rent a motorcycle
and ride through the mountains.
If you have time and find a nice
place to pull over for a [inaudible],
you won't regret it. Oh
Jesus. That sounds great.
Thanks for the laughs and go fuck
yourself. Um, I've actually heard that,
uh, once they make Cuban
cigars legal in America,
like I think initially the quality of
them will go down because the demand will
be through the fucking
roof. And, um, you know,
it's a little ass country over here and
we are a big country that devours shit.
So, um, I was actually talking to a cigar
head the other day and he was saying,
if you going to buy Cuban stock
up on them now, because his fear,
and granted this was just based,
this was just fear talk from
some guy in a fucking cigar bar,
but he was saying that the
quality might drop down. Um,
I liked the fact that we're going to take
our foot off the back of their fucking
neck.
I still think we're going to do the
wrong thing down there and try to get our
cheesecake factories and all that type
of shit and just sort of appropriate them
for our own fucking needs.
Um,
but, uh, I dunno,
there's something fun about the fact
that Cuban cigars are illegal and to
actually have them and no
way to get him and shit.
It's not that fucking hard to get
them, but it's still fun. And, um,
you know,
I was at a party the other day and this
guy showed up and with a box of Cuban
cigars and it was, you know,
we was standing outside
and we smoked in a second.
I took a fucking pull off of it. I
was like, Eh, this is not a Cohiba.
And then he'd given me a,
a party gets however the fuck you say it.
Everybody says it different partake
as part of this is what he gives me.
That series two, which was one of
my favorites. And when I got home,
I looked at it and it was fucking hell.
The band was the same color,
but the font was completely off.
It was a really bad, bad, bad fake.
And through that right in
the fucking trash. So, um,
that's also the fun of it. The Fun. Did
I get a real one? Did I get a fake one?
You know,
there's a lot of cigar people
that go [inaudible] the
Cubans goes virtually full,
can fake well I don't give a fuck
because they taste better than 90% of the
other shit. Um, as far as other, um,
other cigars, yeah, there's a
couple of others that I smoke. Um,
couple of Nicaraguan ones that are right.
Um,
but I'm sick of people always
going through these are
better than the Cubans and
then not, they never are. They, they
just don't taste as good as them. And,
um, it's Kinda like, you know,
when you look at cars and they're always
trying to like compare the car to like
a, like a whatever, a BMW or a, this is
like a Porsche. This is like at this,
it's like, yeah, but it isn't, but
at the end of the day, it isn't.
Even though I heard BMW's quality's been
going down through the fucking, I dunno,
whatever at what happened. Let me just
shut the fuck up. I gotta get Outta here.
I got shit to do. All right. A
happy new year to everybody. Uh,
thanks to everybody who came
out to my shows this year. Uh,
thanks to everybody who's been not
only watching my standup special,
but spreading the word
about it. It's been, um,
it's gotten the best response of
any special I've ever done. And, uh,
getting back to that talent you were born
with and then pushing yourself to get
better. I've been trying to do that with
every special, um, work on a new skill.
Just I can drumming a new drum, lick a
new comedy technique or whatever, um,
to enhance my fucking
bullshit ideas. So, uh,
you know, um, I'm really, yeah, I
couldn't be any happier, so thank you.
And thank you for everybody letting
everybody know about it and, um,
that's it. Happy new year to everybody.
And, uh, thanks to everybody,
anybody who comes out to my shows in
2015. All right, that's the podcast.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'm sticking with the Seattle
Seahawks is my pick for the, um,
for winning the super bowl.
And um,
I'm rooting for Tony Romo.
I want to see him do well and I want
to see him shut all those Dallas Cowboy
fans the fuck up.
That's what I would like the Patriots.
I don't know.
I don't know man.
I think the afcs is once again not as
strong as the NFC. And uh, last week,
this week against the bills,
we had two starting offensive lineman out
and Gronk I think they would just rest
and Gronk. Um, I dunno,
we got to play the Broncos again.
I might have to play the colts again.
We already played them and we won.
Those are always tough. I don't know.
I don't have any foregone conclusions
about what the Patriots are going to do.
Of course, I'm going to be rooting
for them. Uh, that is it. That is all.
Go fuck yourselves.
We'll talk to you next week.